cuando era pequeña había un montón de
cosas que me indignaba empezando por el
colegio donde me quejaba de que las
niñas no pudieran escoger entre llevar
falda y pantalón siguiendo por el
instituto donde tenía un profesor que se
metía conmigo porque de aquella yo ya
decía que era feminista siguiendo por
ese momento en este país que muchas de
las que están en esta sala recordarán
cuando a las mujeres se nos puso en
cuestión el derecho a decidir sobre
nuestros propios cuerpos si queríamos
ser madres o no en el caso de estar
embarazadas
con el paso del tiempo me di cuenta de
que esto no era un pataleo no era que yo
fuera súper quejica sino que tenía
madera de activista
como la mayoría de los que estamos aquí
la generación de los 90 nos criamos
viendo la televisión imágenes sobre el
activismo con personas que luchaban
contra la guerra más concretamente
contra la guerra de irak o esos
activistas de greenpeace que luchaban
con sus barcos contra el deshielo
esta idea casi underground de la
activista que teníamos a partir de 2017
nos dimos cuenta de que iba a cambiar
bases en movimientos como el mito lo que
demostró que el término activista se iba
a volver mainstream y que va a estar
prácticamente en cualquier lugar en la
televisión en la prensa en internet
y tuvo una parte positiva la parte
positiva de que una niña que
posiblemente nunca se hubiera planteado
que era el feminismo gracias a que
beyoncé lo puso en una pantalla enorme
en uno de sus conciertos ahora se llame
feminista
pero también existe una parte negativa
estoy segura de que muchos de vosotros y
muchas de vosotras habréis visto
en grandes tiendas camisetas con
eslóganes revolucionarios sobre libertad
slogans por los que muchos y muchas como
yo arriesgamos nuestro confort y
arriesgamos nuestros privilegios para
ver luego cómo se capitalizan y otros
que no hacen nada sacan provecho de ello
yo con el paso del tiempo y
especialmente a partir de 2013 que es
cuando empiezo a ser activista en el
movimiento en el que estoy hoy femen
entiendo que la activista no es una
persona que haga lo que hace por dinero
ni por aburrimiento
activista es la persona que dedica el
proyecto de su vida a cambiar una
realidad de manera directa
no lo hace por fama no lo hace por
reconocimiento mucho menos por dinero os
lo aseguro
lo hace porque de verdad cree en ello y
de verdad quiere generar un cambio sobre
esa realidad
y cuando incide tanto la palabra directa
es porque siempre surge la duda de que
es divulgación y que es activismo bueno
el activismo os estoy contando lo que es
protestar en el lugar donde existe ese
conflicto esa realidad
y hacer que se escuche tu voz a pesar de
que muchas veces no la quieran escuchar
y la divulgación es lo que estoy
haciendo yo por ejemplo ahora mismo
explicaros qué es lo que hago son
iguales no son complementarias ambas dos
son necesarias para hacer divulgación
sin ser activista a veces puede ser un
riesgo porque estamos hablando sin
experiencia propia
por lo tanto lo que nos ocurre a los
activistas y a las activistas es que no
nos conformamos con estar haciendo
retweet desde el sofá de todo eso que
nos parece súper injusto y está muy bien
lo que hacemos es levantarnos y cambiar
las cosas sin pedir permiso
si pensamos sobre las protestas
qué es una protesta más que un acto de
desobediencia
mirad david tua en el 1848
dijo que la desobediencia es la base
fundamental de cualquier libertad y
estamos en 2019 y yo sigo estando de
acuerdo con esa frase
porque saltarse las normas a veces es lo
más necesario para poder cambiar algo
que es injusto desigual violento racista
o el agente biológico
digamos que el fin justifica los medios
y diréis qué barbaridad de frase eso se
ha usado para justificar grandes
atrocidades a lo largo de la historia
pero es que aquí hay un componente clave
que cambia todo el sentido a eso que es
que los medios son pacíficos la protesta
no violenta o la acción pacífica la
podríamos definir como ese tipo de
protesta política social que sin estar
vinculada a ningún gobierno oa ninguna
institución se presenta dentro del
espacio público para hacer oír su voz de
muchas maneras distintas la mayoría de
las veces de manera especialmente
creativa ha dado que como no nos quieren
escuchar tenemos que inventar reinventar
y seguir buscando la forma
ya os preguntaréis esto realmente sirve
para algo bueno si echamos la vista
atrás hagamos un pequeño ejercicio de
memoria histórica veremos
y pensemos qué hubiera pasado si las
sufragistas no hubieran estado luchando
durante años por el voto femenino
qué hubiera pasado con la guerra de
vietnam y la sociedad estadounidense si
tras años de protestas no hubieran
marchado 500 mil personas alrededor de
la casa blanca en 1971
o qué hubiera ocurrido si por ejemplo
femen no había entrado dentro del
congreso de los diputados en 2013 para
reclamar el derecho de las mujeres a
decidir
[Música]
me encanta recibir aplausos porque
normalmente recibo violenta así que
gracias a que hubiera pasado no
estaríamos ahora aquí por ejemplo la
misma cantidad de hombres y mujeres
tendríamos la misma educación yo creo
que algún mensaje positivo habremos
dejado como legado y habrán dejado estas
personas no sólo el hecho de inspirarnos
a muchos ya muchas sino que cuando vemos
películas sobre activistas lgtb y como
harvey milk' películas contra activistas
antifascistas como sophie scholl o
películas sobre las sufragistas que
hablábamos antes nos demuestra que a
pesar de que todas estas personas no
hayan visto en muchas ocasiones antes de
morir su meta
cumplida merece la pena
aquí es donde hay que admitir que un
activista siempre es más revolucionario
que reformista esto es así nos estamos
saltando las normas y que la utopía es
aquello que nos impulsa realmente a
generar un cambio si pensáramos que no
vamos a conseguir nada nunca haríamos
nada
y a todos nos puede parecer a priori que
una protesta pacífica está genial porque
no estamos empleando la violencia y no
hacemos daño a nadie
pero hay una cosa que se llama libertad
de expresión y eso quiere decir que yo
tengo derecho a accionar y vosotros
tenéis derecho a reaccionar esa reacción
puede estar más de acuerdo con lo que yo
pienso o menos
pero la clave para defender siempre todo
aquello que hagamos será esa libertad de
expresión y eso nunca lo podrán quitar
de cara esto a la gente que no le gusta
lo que hago yo lo que hacemos los
activistas hay una herramienta que son
las redes sociales que sirve para hacer
cosas maravillosas y cosas menos
maravillosas como por ejemplo acosar a
viena llamados de cosas buenísimas que
agradezco mucho hasta cosas e insultos
que no podría enumerar o sinceramente
sin comerme el tiempo del resto de
ponentes
pero eso no es la consecuencia que me
interesa exponer o realmente la
consecuencia que me interesa exponer os
es aquella que ocurre cuando plantamos
nuestra voz y nuestro cuerpo como
resistencia ante algo que es injusto
y os voy a poner un ejemplo
y ha sido detenida por más de 48 horas
en un país que pensamos tan democrático
como suecia o españa he visto mi cara
puesta contra el suelo por activistas
neonazis en francia he estado
secuestrada en marruecos por la policía
casi 24 horas solo por el hecho de
pertenecer a un colectivo feminista y
esto allí pasa a la gente todos los días
y arriesgado hasta seis años de cárcel
por protestar en españa' en la calle de
manera pacífica
bueno para aquellos que todos dicen que
los activistas somos soñadores blanditos
les diré que el inconformismo y la
utopía a veces también duele en el
sentido más literal de la palabra
qué ocurre bueno que está en el fondo es
algo bueno porque en una sociedad
política donde todos decimos nada bueno
mientras sí te parezca bien a mí también
tú en tu sitio y en el mío estamos
obligando que la sociedad se posicione
esos comentarios esos insultos en las
palabras buenas e inspiradoras las
gracias todo sirve para posicionarse
de esto quiero dejar claro una cosa
las activistas no luchamos contra
personas luchamos contra ideas
las ideas son mucho más poderosas que
las personas
de qué nos serviría
atacar a una sola persona y no a lo que
representa el día de mañana otro podría
estar ocupando su lugar desactivar las
ideas que no son justas las ideas que
son desiguales las ideas que son
racistas o violentas es aquello por lo
que hay que luchar realmente
en este caso
pensaréis que merece la pena
bueno ya sinceramente cuando protestó y
alguna acción pienso que yo soy la
fuerte y ellos son los débiles porque yo
estoy buscando la manera de levantarme y
de seguir protestando para cambiar algo
y ellos están empeñados en seguir
oponiéndonos y en seguir intentando
callarnos
el activismo 3
más cosas buenas que malas a la vida de
verdad aunque después de lo que os dicho
podréis pensar lo contrario pero traer
cosas mucho mejores más cosas buenas
como por ejemplo una comunidad donde
sentirte segura conocer a personas a lo
largo del mundo que están intentando
hacer lo mismo que tú de acuerdo a otros
temas
y sentir que estás aprovechando tu
juventud en especial en la energía que
la caracteriza para generar de verdad un
impacto y cambiar una realidad
ejerciendo eso lo que yo pienso como la
responsabilidad que tienen los seres
humanos a la hora de participar dentro
de la sociedad
yo decidí ser rebelde y yo decidí
desobedecer yo decidí hacer cosas que en
muchos aspectos podrían ser ilegales
para cambiar la situación de las mujeres
no solo en españa sino a nivel global
y obligar a aquellos que no quieren
escuchar a escucharnos lo que tenemos
que decir mostrar la cara real de las
cosas y hacer que la sociedad se
posicionase
pintando me un eslogan encima de mi
cuerpo saliendo a ser una mujer rebelde
y de verdad con muy pocos segundos y muy
pocas palabras intentar cambiar las
cosas
estoy hoy aquí
en esta cuestión hay dos opciones
podemos seguir quedándonos sentados en
nuestra casa sin hacer nada haciendo
retweet dando like
desde la pasividad
o levantarnos y empezar a cambiar las
cosas por nosotras mismas nosotros
mismos y nosotras mismas muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]